Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
In this series, we frequently talk about Generative
Adversarial networks, or GANs in short.
This means a pair of neural networks that
battle each over time to master a task, for
instance, to generate realistic looking images
from a written description.
Here you see NVIDIA’s amazing work that
was able to dream up high-resolution images
of imaginary celebrities.
In the next episode, we will talk some more
about their newest work that does something
like this, and is even better at it, believe
it or not.
I hope you have subscribed to the channel
to make sure not to miss out on that one.
And for now, while we marvel at these outstanding
results, I will quickly tell you about overfitting
and what it has to do with images of celebrities.
When we train a neural network, we wish to
make sure that it understands the concepts
we are trying to teach it.
Typically, we feed it a database of labeled
images, where the labels mean that this depicts
a dog, and this one is not a dog, but a cat.
After the training step took place, in the
ideal case it will be able to build an understanding
of these images, so that when we show them
new, previously unseen pictures, it would
be able to correctly guess which animals they
depict.
However, in many cases, we start training
the neural network, and during the training,
it gives us wonderful results, and it gets
the animals right every single time!
But, whenever it sees new, previously unseen
images, it can’t tell a dog from a cat at
all.
This peculiar case is what we call overfitting,
and this is the bane of machine learning research.
Overfitting is like the kind of student we
all encountered at school who is always very
good at memorizing the textbook but can’t
solve even the simplest new problems on the
exam.
This is not learning, this is memorization!
Overfitting means that a neural network does
not learn the concept of dogs or cats, it
just tries to memorize this database of images
and is able to regurgitate it for us, but
its knowledge cannot generalize for new images.
That’s not good.
I want intelligence, not a copying machine!
So at this point, it is probably clearer what
images of celebrities have to do with overfitting.
So, how do we know that this algorithm doesn’t
just memorize the celebrity image dataset
it was given, and can really generate new,
imaginary people?
Is it the good kind of student, or the lousy
student?
Technique number one, let’s not just dream
up images of new celebrities, but also visualize
images from the training data that are similar
to this image.
If they are too similar, we have an overfitting
problem.
Let’s have a look.
Now it is easy to see that this is proper
intelligence, and not a copying machine, because
it was clearly able to learn the facial features
of these people and combine them in novel
ways.
This is what scientists at NVIDIA did in their
paper and are to be commended for that.
Technique number two, well, just take a bunch
of humans and let them decide whether these
images differ from the training set and if
they are realistic.
This kinda works, but of course, costs quite
a bit of money, labor, and we end up with
something subjective.
We better not compare the quality of research
papers based on that if we can avoid it.
And get this, we can actually avoid it by
using something called the inception score.
Instead of using humans, this score uses a
neural network to have a look at these images
and measure the quality and the diversity
of the results.
As long as the image produces similar neuron
activations within this neural network, two
images will be deemed to be similar.
Finally, this score is an objective way of
measuring progress within this field, and
it is of course, subject to maximization.
So now, you, of course, wish to know what
the state of the art is today.
For reference, a set of real images has an
inception score of 233, and the best works
that produced synthetic images from just a
few years ago had a score of around 50.
To the best of my knowledge, as of the publishing
of this video, the highest inception score
for an AI is close to 166, so we’ve come
a long long way.
You can see some of these images here.
Truly exciting — what a time to be alive!
The disadvantages of the method is that one,
because the diversity of the outputs is also
to be measured, it requires many thousands
of images.
This is likely more of an issue with the problem
definition itself, not this method, and also,
since this means that the computers and not
real people have to do more work, … we can
give this one a pass.
Disadvantage number two, I will include this
paper in the video description for you, which
basically describes that there are cases where
it is possible to get the network to think
an image is of higher quality than another
one even if it clearly isn’t.
Now you see that we have pretty ingenious
techniques to measure the quality of image
generator AI programs, and of course, this
area of research is also subject to improvement,
and, I’ll be here to tell you about it.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!